tick tock is where i get my most
important
uh un understanding of the current
obsession with
race and sex and gender in particular
here's a
gal on tick tock explaining
what it means to be gender fluid oh
actually i'm gender fluid
oh okay wait what does gender fluid mean
again
gender fluid means my gender changes
depending on the
day or week or even depending on the
hour
it also means the pronouns i'm
comfortable with can change too
oh so how do i know what pronouns to use
for you and other gender fluid people
we all express them differently but
personally i express them through
color-coded bracelets
pink means she her yellow means they
them
and blue means he him and if i'm
comfortable with more than one pronoun i
will
combine them oh okay so today's uh
she day day you got it
okay um i'll keep that in mind okay you
got it
you got it do you see this is obviously
a confused gal so i'm not gonna go after
her too much i think that she is
expressing a very popular point of view
and no one gets the problem did you
catch the problem with her
solution how do i know if you're a boy
or a girl today well you can tell by my
bracelet if i'm wearing the blue
bracelet it means this one thing if i'm
wearing this other brace it means
another thing
who decides what the bracelets mean
right now we looking at the symbols of
our bodies
we say that certain physical
characteristics
body parts things like that
represent man or woman
and then the radicals came in and said
you can't tell me that my adam's apple
and my broad shoulders and my other
appendages represent man they actually
could represent woman i'm a woman you
just
are misunderstanding the symbols of my
body
okay so how am i going to know if you're
a man or woman well i'm going to wear a
color-coded bracelet
well then how are you you can't be the
one to decide what the pink and the blue
mean it's
it's exactly the same problem it just
pushes it back ultimately
someone needs to decide what these
symbols mean whether the symbol
is words whether the symbol is color or
whether the symbol is our body itself
you can read about
how to make sense of these things and
why the conservatives have just
completely
whiffed it on this issue in my upcoming
book speechless hitting bookstores
tomorrow
this has become a national obsession and
it's very very confused
and it leads people to make hasty and
incorrect conclusions
hey i'm so glad that you liked that
video there's a whole show there's an
entire episode out there that you can
get what's the title
knives at a gunfight head on over and
check it out on youtube
on the apple podcasts app on spotify and
stitcher on google play and you can
pre-order my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds ring
the bell subscribe we'll see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you